now to the big bucks and I touched on
this at the start of the show this week
the salaries of close to a million
federal employees came under question in
the United States because Democrats and
Republicans couldn't manage to meet a
deadline on a new spending bill how can
things go so wrong in the world's
mightiest economy that's a question for
hans-peter Bork off from the University
of horn hype well as an external
observer we would assume that is because
the United States has got too much depth
the depth isn't weezing much too fast
and therefore maybe Israel Republicans
found out that they should spend less
they should help and Lesnar's dead but
fact is it's not be called that it's
because well the government wants to
finance a project which the Republicans
despise and also try to blackmail the
government into not continuing with this
project and well this is a political
haggle and this political heavy leads to
bright damage for the whole United
States is that really what it all comes
down to political bickering because
after years of ducking crises and coming
in with last-minute deals all the time
this time it didn't work I think I found
a way you know now together pressure on
the government and well try to change
the course of politics made the law it's
about Obama care Medicare care and sure
the health care insurance for for people
with low incomes and this is law so it
should take place but now as I say but
maybe it should take place but we don't
give you any money for that you must
abstain from that what's a power
conflict what what does it say about the
United States as a whole well it's a big
problem seemingly they've got big
problems to to find the center of
politics and so the extremes are ruling
and the extremes are highly influenced
in its particulars Republican Party
because nobody dares to stand up against
this kind of extremist policies and
likewise they've got a lack of respect
for the institutional order of United
States because it just abuse their
rights as a member of parliament or
Senate of the representative house only
can they afford this type of abuse no
country can afford it I mean the United
States can better than any other country
on earth because there's a particular
rich
but on the other hand they had a big
economic crisis they were recovering
somewhat it's not a good idea just in
this recovery to build up news problems
and such a well it's such a flagrant
Tory way and how damaging was the last
shutdown back in the 90s tattoos I have
never seen a number on how much damage
was done the big problem is that many
plans many individual plans have to be
changed as a government isn't properly
working and nobody can put put a price
tag on that also this was the deadline
before the deadline so to speak if we
take a look at the very interesting
trajectory that federal debt is on the
level has tripled since 2000 the current
amount is staggering 17 trillion dollars
Republicans and Democrats have to agree
on a new debt ceiling by mid month
what's going to happen if they can't
well let me say one point the political
logic to blackmail the government is the
same as in the discussion we have today
so it should happen if the Republicans
Republicans don't change their course
but this would be worse it's the worst
case because this situations United
States won't pay its debt so it won't
pay interest so there will be
repercussions all around the globe in
the debt market because now first time
the United States really failed on that
end and what repercussions global equity
is taking a huge hit I guess so I think
it will be some some turmoil of the
capital market because everybody who has
invested his well he's safe investment
invested money in government bonds
government bonds won't get is interest
so everybody has to change his plans so
there will be a big reshuffling of
investments and there might be some
distress as well because many rely on
having this interesting cut but at the
same time interest rates could stay low
agree I mean the interest rates of
United States are staying low at the
moment because it gives the Federal
Reserve Board it's manipulating the
interest rate so most of the bonds
United States issue today well not most
but many of them are just bought by the
Federal Reserve and this leads to low
interest rate so it's something like
manipulation it's not the economic
reality in reality is not set has lost
much of its reputation and should pay a
pay higher interest rate mr. Broekhoff
thank you very much for coming out later